thank you good morning everybody and
welcome to this latest meeting of the
traffic covered 19 public engagement
board can i just thank you for your
attendances
clear that screen there and i have
apologies this morning from george
devlin ali khadix sarah radcliffe
council zachinola councillor chilton and
laura hobbs are there any further
apologies at all
i don't see any are there any
declarations of interest in today's
agenda at all
thank you
the minutes of the last meeting come we
take them as read please as a true and
accurate record
thank you for that
we'll move on to item 4 then the update
on the latest covert 19 situation in
trafford over to ellen good morning
eleanor
morning um and thank you chair so um the
latest situation is that um our rates
are still high although fortunately um
they seem to be plateauing i think last
time we met they were they were starting
to go up again
but they are still worryingly high and
they're particularly high in our older
population um or rather they are um
they have increased more in that
population where we had typically seen
quite low rates so what we're seeing
across the borough is we've got high
rates in every ward we're over 300 and
our rates of total rates about 335 per
hundred thousand every ward bar one has
rates of over 200 per hundred thousand
and the award that is below 200 is i
think 196 per hundred thousand highest
wards is about 545. so i think we're
seeing we we have in the past seen quite
a lot of discrepancy between between
different areas but what we're seeing is
um the rates by different age group the
variation in that has dropped and the
variation in rates across different
wards has also dropped so we're seeing
quite a widespread pattern of covet
infection by age group and by
by geography within the borough
um we know that um one of the as i say
the our over 60s rates is up around 190
per hundred thousand rate
which is much higher than we would want
it to be um obviously most of that
population has now been vaccinated and
the vaccination is holding well
but we need to help the vaccination we
can't make the vaccination do everything
on its own it won't work that way we
really do need to continue to remember
that covid is a very real threat and
that we need to manage our behaviors
accordingly so i'm really encouraging
people to maintain that social
distancing especially and wear face
coverings in crowded areas think about
the needs of others as well as
yourselves
please do go and get that vaccination i
know that on the
news today there was news about the the
um effectiveness of the vaccination
waning over time
and
often that does happen but waning isn't
the same as stopping being infective and
it was it's coming from a very very high
level of effectiveness so i would
absolutely thoroughly recommend anybody
who hasn't been vaccinated please do and
get that vaccination now because many of
the hospitalizations are most the
seriously ill people are in our
unvaccinated population
i would particularly encourage pregnant
women
or anyone who's thinking if they or
their partner are thinking of having a
baby please don't get that vaccination
straight away do get please get
vaccinated now because um we've seen
some you know across the country we've
seen such tragic deaths of um of women
and um really the best thing you can do
for you and your baby is to make sure
you get that vaccine now it's very safe
and it's very safe in pregnancy there is
no risk to you or to your baby from
having that vaccination
um
equally anyone with any extra risk
factors again please just we do need to
get the vaccination rates up now the 16
and 17 year olds um are going actually
in their droves and i think we're
certainly seeing actually that our 16 to
25 year olds are getting we're getting
very good uptake of vaccination in those
age groups but overall in all of our
groups we've had um you know the
majority well over two-thirds in any age
group is vaccinated so it is a minority
that is not vaccinated it is the norm to
be vaccinated
so if you think that
if you're worried that your friends
aren't getting vaccinated or that it's
um that you'd be you know you're unusual
absolutely not the unusual thing now is
not to be vaccinated
um 16 and 17 year olds so everybody
should have been contacted now
we've got and rebecca will talk about
the um exactly how to get the
vaccination and where where the clinics
are being advertised
um
and we are also still waiting to hear
about the booster vaccination program
ben will talk to us about the antibody
testing program um
and the other things i think that have
changed since last time we spoke was
that we now if you are if you've been
vaccinated um you no longer need to um
self-isolate
and so that does that's very good news
for people but i would encourage people
to think well especially if somebody in
your household is positive do remember
that you are quite likely to be
continuing to get that exposure so do be
very very cautious and i would say to
anyone in that situation if you can work
from home do continue to work from home
don't don't don't take that risk
anywhere and do remember that you could
be carrying um covid so if there is
cases if you've been exposed if even if
you don't have to self-isolate do be
very very cautious about who you see
where you see them so staying outside is
absolutely the safest thing at the
moment
i think
i think that's um probably oh and the
other thing is i think worryingly um and
this is the broader things but again
we're getting the evidence that smoking
rates went up in the first lockdown and
particularly in younger people also
alcohol use i mean smoking remains the
biggest single killer
so absolutely if you have started
smoking or if you're smoking more than
you were do please get in touch do start
thinking about
reducing and stopping smoking because
that is the you know the single biggest
thing you can do that will help improve
your health so it absolutely is that
message now you know we're coming to the
end of august
and think about getting ready for winter
be as healthy as you can for winter um
and that means you know thinking about
your diet thinking about physical
activity be more active we really don't
want to see people going back into
self-isolating or shielding because we
know how bad that has been for people's
physical and mental health so it really
is about trying to be as active as you
can see your friends be as social as you
can but just with that added degree of
caution um and having that little new
normal of those two meter distancing etc
and being outdoors
but please please please do do go out do
enjoy yourselves and um if you need
support to stop smoking uh there's
support on the website and we can help
thanks
thank you and i think it's really
encouraging news about the 16 to 25 year
olds and the updates of the vaccination
uh it really is good news are there any
questions at all from anyone for uh mike
cordingley
yeah um
the
hospitals how how are hospitalizations
going locally and
across greater manchester
so at the moment that it's relatively
stable um but we still do have a lot of
people in covid beds i think about 200
um in the mri beds um
so it is it is still a significant
pressure on our hospital system but
luckily the vaccination program has been
so effective that many people are it
tends to be younger people and they so
they tend to be in better health overall
but um obviously it's it's not you know
we we don't want to see anyone
hospitalized and we and we are seeing
deaths every week so um the hospitals
are coping they are predicting an
increase in hospital activity especially
as we're starting to see across greater
manchester we're starting to see rates
going up in the over 60s
and that as as i say is our most the
group that we are most worried about at
the moment the hospitals are doing well
but they are predicting an increase in
activity and of course that's against a
backdrop of massive increase in hospital
activity just dealing with the backlog
of all the work that was going on
previously so they really are trying to
and it's also meaning because treatments
got better for covid people are more
used to dealing with covid it's also
putting pressure on our primary care
services because many people who might
have been admitted to hospital in
earlier waves are being able to be
managed at home but that obviously does
require a lot of primary care and
community service support not and added
to that the issues around long covered
so overall we are seeing and a big
increase in um
demand on nhs and social care services
due to covid and it but it's not all at
the sort of dramatic icu end some of it
is now happening through the primary
care and other services but we're in
this position at the moment of of staff
being exhausted as i'm sure you can
understand and
increasing demands just because and also
because people are out and about more
some of the things that weren't
happening last year some of the you know
accidents and things like that are
starting to happen again so we're seeing
seeing the normal activity ramp up that
you would often see in july and august
anyway just because people
are out and about and doing more things
so it really is a sort of plea to
everybody to absolutely seek medical
attention when you need it you
absolutely must whether it's for covid
or any other condition but at the same
time do try and do everything you can to
keep yourself safe
thank you ellen your counselor black
book counselor blackburn
thank you
um
on the
shiny app
um
sorry just a minute
sorry about that thank you pardon sorry
about that i want to switch it up yeah
on the shiny up it's got the um mft uh
data well that would be for all all
residents in gm that that goes to say uh
manchester royal but you know yeah yeah
it doesn't happen
and
we we don't have it by trafford although
we can probably get that from the um we
can ask um
uh i don't know if the we can probably
do some analyses by trafford but what we
tend to use is that group data obviously
some of our residents will also go to
salford
yes the other thing i just wanted to ask
obviously about three four weeks ago we
were
amongst the bottom two or three in gm
and we're now in the top three um
have has it risen so much
because we were one of the lower ones
and the only way was up or have you got
a reason why we've actually risen so
much compared to the other gm boroughs
we've
we've
we've basically stayed about the same
and they went down and then we we
started to go down they went down
further
and we're start we have stayed very
stable um
quite often i my theory and a lot of
this has been that trafford often starts
to go up before other places but we also
come down more quickly and i'm sure
that's partly to do with demographics um
in that if you've got a barrel with
people who are you know we're the most
affluent borough in greater manchester
and in the main that means that people
have good living conditions
and that means that if people do get
coveted it's easier for them to
self-isolate they may be more likely to
do jobs that don't involve face-to-face
work they've got more space in their
houses so that if somebody's ill they
may not be sharing a room with other
people so and they may have more space
so people can they can have that space
and so on so um in the main
we we seem to come down but this what
we're seeing with this
time is we haven't really come down we
went up we came down but we haven't come
down as far as we've come down in any of
the previous ones and actually what i
think we're seeing um our positivity
rates haven't gone up too much which
which is good our testing rates are um
have gone up a little bit this week
but what we're seeing in some age groups
are 11 to 16 year olds who were testing
loads at school
of course with school holidays they're
probably not testing anymore um but
we're seeing a very high positivity rate
in the children who do
who do go for a test we're seeing a very
high a high number of them are coming
back positive about 40 percent which
implies to me that there's probably
quite a lot of and you know if you're
if you're not really going to take a
child for a test in that age group
unless they're ill
and so i i suspect that we have quite a
few people who have subclinical symptoms
in that age group who may be positive we
may start picking up a lot of those when
schools go back
because they're going to start doing
that routine testing again so i am
expecting to see a surge in numbers when
schools go back but i think that will
mainly be because we're fine we'll be
finding the people who have got um
milder cases the disease at the moment
in that age group the important thing
about finding them is if we know where
they are we can encourage that you know
they they will be self-isolating then
and we can make sure that their families
and so on are taking adequate
precautions to stop spread so as i say i
think um we may be we may be under under
diagnosing at the moment
okay thank you
thank you thank you are there any
further questions at all
yes my counselor welton and then i'll
come to council accordingly afterwards
um
thanks so chad um
just uh you know you were mentioning the
pressures uh that the nhs is under i
know we had the altria minor injuries
unit opening briefly and then
unfortunately closing again due to the
uh higher rates and renewed pressures i
presume we're looking at a sort of a
prolonged close closure at the moment at
least until the schools have gone back
um i don't know if you uh if you have
any clues about that for local residents
um i'm going to refer that one to
rebecca as my ccg colleague um i'm sure
rebecca will have an answer to that one
sorry i'm just trying to
get on camera and on microphone just
repeat the question again please
counselor
uh just regarding the alternate minor
injuries uh unit obviously we
elena was talking about the pressures
that the nhs uh uh
are under um and obviously we had the
the unit
it was welcome that it reopened again
but obviously when the cases went up
again and um yeah it closed and i was
just wondering you know if there's any
kind of time scale for a decision is
being made today and we have um our
comms
um ready with um an announcement to um
stakeholders so that decision will be
made at the um strategic group today
great thank you very much
no problem watch this space watch this
space yeah thank you
thanks for the question councilwoman i
think we we all of us here would agree
that during this uh that the situation
it's vital that the staff go where
they're absolutely needed at the moment
and and uh
and you know i look forward to the to
the communication this afternoon but i
think that that's the position that i
i i as chair would believe in that we
need to ensure that the staff go where
they're needed council accordingly
thanks chair um
yeah just a quick question in terms of
um
the messaging uh and it's in some ways
it's
i i suppose this applies to every
director of public health in england
anyway
it seems to me it's much harder to get
the message over
now that it's a serious thing i've just
be i spent the weekend in the brecon
beacons which is wales of course
and you know there's a pandemic in wales
because everybody wears masks
it may not need it any more than in
england uh they may need it more i do it
doesn't matter the very fact that
they're wearing masks
tells me i'm in a place where there's a
pandemic
that doesn't apply you could tell it as
service stations an english service
station almost no adherence
this is
there's no pandemic in england according
to the service stations that's the sort
of subliminal message that's coming
across
how do directors of public health in
england
struggle against this because it really
is
unless you see it
something's visible it's really hard to
get that message across and i i
personally think people are
forgetting about it now
it's it's a really it's a really good
question and it's one we've been
grappling with as you say as directors
of public health because
we want people to have
as normal a life as they can and you
know we we would we were expecting the
rates to go up um with the restrictions
lifting the vaccination has been doing
really well
um but it is still it's still a very
real threat and and i think my big worry
is that people feel that it's over and
they haven't been vaccinated and they
then don't need to be vaccinated or that
actually you know it's fine to be in in
really you know um and again it's this
thing about making sure that we
we it's such an unpredictable disease at
the moment we still don't really know
what our own risks are we have seen some
awful cases of people who have been
completely fit and well who've come to
it and and died we've seen other people
um you know including some very frail
older people get it and and recover and
be absolutely fine so it's it's a very
odd disease but what is very what's very
clear is that long covid is is a is
particularly nasty it's it's um it
doesn't seem to be one thing it's
several things um
and some of it is is probably you know
that the um a standard post viral thing
there's other issues with lungs with
other other um parts of the body it
really is a very nasty disease
and
it's not something that i think we
should you know i i absolutely think we
have to continue to take it very
seriously and i i'm i'm with you i think
on the face coverings they do provide
some protection to other people and
therefore as a courtesy to others even
if you don't think that they're doing
much for yourself i do think it's really
important that we continue to wear them
i think it's really important that we
continue to think about
the spaces we're in that we make outdoor
spaces as possible as pleasant as
possible and we think about how we're
going to manage that through the winter
without all getting hypothermia but i
think and and we need to think about how
we make sure that our society is really
inclusive so that older people and
people who are vulnerable are able to
engage are able to get out because
actually one of the worst things now is
for people to get frightened again and
stay in their houses because we do all
need to be out we need to have you know
we're a social animal we need social
contact it's good for us sunshine is
good for us well it would be nice
if we had any but you know even being
outdoors a bit it you know that fresh
air that walking around that keeping
physically active is so important for us
and we really do need to make sure that
we're doing that and we're not behaving
in a way that we're not behaving in a
way that makes other people worried so i
am really you know especially in
supermarkets i would really
in any place where where people should
you know need to be any any
communal spaces you know at urged
restaurants i know it's really hard but
do keep those spacing of your tables as
much as you can
um and in um in supermarkets keep keep
two meters away from other people don't
don't
shuff you know don't cue really close to
people give everybody that space so that
we can all we can all use those communal
spaces and it's it's a really good and i
think the other thing is that i think
we've all learned so much about our
local areas haven't we and all the all
the parks and all the rest of it so it's
a real opportunity for us to look at our
green and blue space and make sure that
where that's really pleasant and
welcoming for everybody in our community
through through the autumn and winter so
that we can keep getting out and about
but i would absolutely implore people to
continue to take this seriously and show
that you're taking it seriously by
wearing that face mask
thank you thanks for the question
council accordingly um
the sun is coming out this afternoon and
reliably informed ellen and i for one i
am still wearing a mask in enclosed
spaces supermarkets uh out and about
but you do my council called is
absolutely right you know you are
becoming in the minority
and and uh you know you
i suppose we stuck with the policy that
the english government have given us and
that's unfortunate because i would agree
with council accordingly that in wales
and i have been to wells recently yeah
you have to wear a mask
and and and you do know that that you
know and and
you know there's still a pandemic
any further questions at all
can we move on then to the next item on
the agenda and that's the self-isolation
pathfinder update from kirsty good
morning kirsty hi good morning
um so the pathfinder um obviously we've
spoken about this before at the public
engagement board
there's three elements to self-isolation
support
and there's a 500 pound grant that
people may
be eligible for if they've lost income
or if they're on
related benefits where they
may be able to apply for that
there's a self-isolation framework where
that's around practical support so both
of those are accessed via access
trafford
and then we've got the pathfinder which
we've been running for a period of 10
weeks now so we've got another couple of
weeks left we're due to run it until
mid-september and the pathfinder is
about proactively contacting
every single case positive case in m15
and m16 postcode areas
in the last few weeks we've also rolled
that out to m32 and m33 postcode areas
so all positive cases receive a call
just asking do they require any support
whilst they're self-isolating
so
the the we've managed to reach over a
thousand individuals so far throughout
the duration of the pathfinder
and the calls have been really well
received by people even if they've said
no i'm fine i don't require any support
and the they're appreciative of the call
we have provided support to over 150
people
um by that proactive phone call so
uptake has been relatively low however
that is the case across greater
manchester as part of this wider
pathfinder
and within the past couple of weeks
we've introduced um food vouchers um so
we've been issuing those to people for
asda
and that is just a more speedier way of
getting that support to people when
they've been in need
of food as predominantly food is the is
the main reason and that people require
support followed by financial so then we
sign post them to the 500 pound grant
so as i said that's due to ending in a
couple of weeks we're having discussions
today
on whether that's going to continue
until all funding has has been utilized
and that's going to be a gm wide
decision
in terms of the 500 point grant in the
framework um
that that funding was due to end i think
it was the
end of august and that has been extended
until the end of september
i think that's that's it for the update
on the pathfinder
thank you thank you kirsten and so
that's very welcome news about the the
the 500 pound grant being accepted to
the end of september any questions at
all from anybody
thank you that's a very useful update
thank you very much
um we now move on to the next item mass
testing with ben good morning ben
good morning chair thank you very much
so i've got a few updates today starting
off with the one that element ellen
mentioned which is the antibody
surveillance program
so this is the first antibody
surveillance program that's available to
the general public
um home antibody tests are now available
for 8 000 people per day that launched
yesterday so the aim of it is to help
improve understanding of covert immunity
from vaccinations and from infections
and how it will work is that people will
be randomly selected
and it will be offered out to adults
adults only who registered for a pcr
test with the assumption being that if
you opt in you'll then be sent the
antibody tests if you test positive um
you'll be given two fingerprint
fingerprint tests to take one straight
away and once 28 days after testing
positive
both of which need to be set back to
with lab for processing
and the implications of this is it will
allow the uk health security agency to
see how well vaccinated individuals
boost their immunity when they're
infected and how this might vary with
different variants so i think the key
thing that we're trying to get across is
that we want to encourage as many people
as possible to par in this research
study um if they're selected but it is a
research study so regardless of the
results people should continue to follow
good practices so all the stuff that
eleanor spoke about before ensuring
they've got good ventilation washing
their hands staying outdoors if possible
and meeting people
um so that's yeah the antibody
surveillance programme my next update is
around the new types of water flow tests
that i mentioned two weeks ago
so um as i said we have the orient gene
test and the new acon flowflex test
which you've taken over from the noble
ones
the key difference between them and lean
over kits is that they're nasal only as
opposed to nasal and throat and they
only take 15 minutes to get the results
we were previously told so i think i've
mentioned last week that the owing jeans
test with on-site testing and the
flow-flex ones with home testing
this is now no longer the case so for
example if you were to go and order um
any kits online to come to your house
you would get given one here the origin
ones whereas if you just went to a
pharmacy library etc then you go pick up
some of the flowflex ones
essentially
these two are
basically the same there are some very
small differences in terms of um how
long you need to go and leave the swap
in the tube for um but i think our key
message is just read the instructions um
look what they say and and you won't go
wrong
so the final thing then is around
schools so we're going to be supporting
a number of secondary schools when they
return in september with the two on-site
tests that those peoples need to take
and then following these pupils will be
asked to take the test throughout
september at home on a twice weekly
basis we are still waiting to find out
what happens um from
october onwards
and then finally obviously just to
emphasize um in terms of our key
messages please continue to um to test
especially at the moment um
there is every indication that with
pupils going going back and universities
going back and that we do strategy cases
rise potentially soon and therefore this
is a really really crucial time
especially if you ask someone that does
come into contact with us on a regular
basis or come into contact with those
who are vulnerable if you visit people
in care homes for instance so please
continue testing for the time being and
obviously that key key message of if you
have any sort of symptoms please go and
get yourself a pcr test as soon as
possible and that's all from each other
thank you ben any questions at all from
anyone for ben
i don't see any answer thank you ben
um
the next item is um uh contract tracing
and outbreak management eleanor can i
come to you because i don't see helen or
kate on the call
that's fine and kirsty has been stepping
into this as well so yeah um
but at the moment well i'll let kate
because you talk about the details we
have um quite a few businesses still
with outbreaks going on and also
obviously
it's been much quieter since schools
were off um but we still have quite a
few cases in early years settings so um
i think the main thing with both of
those is trying to make sure that people
understand all the rules around
self-isolation because it has got it's
got quite confusing about who who can
and can't be self-isolating and so on
but if i ask um kirsty to um talk a
little bit about what they've been doing
yes so i'm just going to share my screen
because i have got a couple of key
messages around the people that do need
to be
self-isolating and what the changes mean
and
can we see that
so obviously um closed contacts are no
longer required to isolate if they're
fully vaccinated and if they're under
the age of 18 years in six months
are they taking part in an approved call
with vaccine trial
or if they're not able to be vaccinated
for medical reasons now the medical
reasons for
um exemption to to not having the
vaccine are very very minimal and so i
would encourage people to
check those medical reasons because they
are really really minimal as to why
people can't have the vaccine
so if you are identified as a close
contact now um you strongly advise to
take a pcr test and limit social contact
as eleanor has mentioned
and you should encourage anyone
identified as a close contact to do that
people should not have a pcr test if
they've tested positive within the last
90 days unless new symptoms do develop
and then those identified as close
contacts
they will not need to isolate while
they're awaiting the result of the pcr
test so they can continue as normal
and obviously if the pcr is positive
they must continue to isolate as
previously
and nhs testing trace we'll work with
them to identify close contacts
um we're advising that children age four
and under they won't need to have a pcr
test if they're identified as a close
contact unless
the
the positive case is somebody within
their household
ellen has touched on some of this
previously but as well as getting that
pcr test if somebody's a close contact
you should also be considering limiting
that social contact particularly with
people outside your household and
especially in enclosed spaces
we're in a face covering particularly in
enclosed spaces and where you can't
maintain social distancing
limiting contact with anybody who's
clinically extremely vulnerable
and if you if you are attending the
workplace or just in general take place
take part in twice weekly lfd testing
and those are the measures that we
recommend to put in place for the full
10 days after that they may have been a
close contact with somebody
and it still remains that if anybody
develops symptoms no matter how mild
they should self-isolate immediately
arrange that pcr test and follow the
self-isolation guidance so that's corvid
related symptoms and that they should
follow that guidance
and then just those general good
practice measures
of um reducing the spread of the virus
vaccination obviously that's key for
those that are eligible
testing if you have been if you if you
do know that you're a close contact and
even if you've not been contacted by
test and trace but you know that you're
a contact then then follow that up with
a pcr test continue lfd testing the
social distancing
good hygiene measures the catch it
bennett kill it um and
ventilation in in spaces where they they
are enclosed we still need to practice
frequent hand washing
and maintain cleaning
regimes particularly in workplaces
schools and nurseries
and and more so following a positive
case
so i just thought i'd um
brief those key messages out there have
we got any questions before i move on
further with contact tracing
just um i was just going to add kirsty
the point about the exemption i think
lots of people think that they may be
medically exempt from vaccination
because they've had um maybe they've got
an allergy or whatever um but actually
they covered the exemptions for covid
and the contraindications covered are
very very narrow they are um they're
much narrower than for some other um
vaccination programs so
if people think that that
the it's likely that you would still
have to self-isolate um unless your gp
has said you're medically exempt or
unless you've got some medical
certification so it's just making sure
people are aware of that because i think
i think often people think that they may
be um they can't have a vaccination when
when in general they they actually can
so it's just just so people are aware um
to check whether they actually are
medically exempt
thanks elena
and then wider with the local contact
racing within trafford so
we've with no schools in at present
they're due to return next week
and the lfd programs will be starting
with on-site school so we will probably
expect to see a rise in in positive
cases with that testing programme
starting again
um
predominantly in within education
settings the cases are within early
years because they're the only education
settings that are
in
in in school or or the setting at the
minute
so
the
cases are mainly in staff um across
early years
we are preparing for schools returning
so we've got a number of materials that
we're sharing with schools so they're
ready and prepared for the return in
september
we're continuing to work with businesses
and contact trace in those so there is
still an element of contact racing
across businesses and schools because we
do have unvaccinated individuals within
businesses so we're working with around
about 26 workplace settings that have
currently got cases across
trafford and we're also continuing to
work with the trafford centre
then we've got the
contact tracing um
[Music]
which is known as the level two contact
racing and they are cases that haven't
been managed to reach by the national
team and they get passed over to local
authority so we we're still continuing
with contact tracing of those
um
and we have a relatively
successful
rate of contact with those individuals
although it is something that we would
like to it to increase
but we are still reaching those people
that the national team haven't managed
to reach
i think that's from me in terms of
contact tracing any questions
i don't see any cursive can i just say
that um as we know uh it's the the
contact tracing for for schools is to go
national isn't it from uh september
but we are still couldn't confirm we are
still going to offer support to our
local schools
until this is panned out and and we know
exactly how it's going to work
nationally
most definitely yes there's a couple of
grey areas in terms of of that national
offer to schools so we're still very
much here and available and and that's
the message the key message that we're
giving out to schools we still want them
to notify us of positive cases parents
should still be notifying um
school their school if if their child
does test positive and we're fully here
to support schools
thank you that's very reassuring to know
are there any any questions at all
i don't see any cursing thank you very
much for your contribution uh the next
item on the agenda is uh mass
vaccination over to rebecca welcome
rebecca
thank you chair um so pleased to hear
colleagues obviously just reinforcing
the message about the importance of the
vaccination so um i'll just give um a
number of updates in the context of that
so as of um today the current numbers
across trafford and this is total doses
so includes first and second and it's
just over 317 000 and so that's quite an
increase from last time i presented um
which is good and um including within
that we've now delivered over a thousand
first doses to the 16 17 year old
cohorts even though it's only been a
couple of weeks um which again is really
positive and as ellen mentioned we are
seeing a um
a faster uptake in that cohort than we
did in the 18 to 29 year old so um some
positive um news coming out of that the
16 17 year olds are being invited by
their um gps if their gp practice is
signed up to phase two of the delivery
they're also getting a national um text
which advises them of both the mass
vaccination sites and
local vaccination sites as well so
currently we have um walking clinics at
all of our current sites and all of the
pharmacies and all of the networks are
delivering um walk-in clinics if they
sign up to phase two
we do have one pharmacy that isn't yet
delivering to 16 17 year olds that's the
partington pharmacy um but they have got
a plan in place to be able to deliver
that from next week so um
that will be um covered next week
because we're aware of potential some
inequalities there and that was just in
relation to um staff training but
they're on on course to deliver that so
um that's good
um as of last as of this week um as of
monday the um eligibility criteria was
opened up to clinically extremely
vulnerable 12 to 15 year olds um we have
three of our networks currently um
inviting those um vulnerable 12 to 15
year olds in and we're just working
through
the other sites and the other networks
and with the clinically extremely
vulnerable it's slightly different as
they cannot be seen by a community
pharmacy site only a network site or a
hospital hub and so again we're just
working with mft about the inviting to
the hospital hub as well
um in terms of where we're up to with
the booster program um we have had no
further guidance on the rollout of the
booster programme
um so
as and when we get that um obviously
we'll let you know but what we do know
is that the flu program does commence on
the 6th of september so we've got
confirmation of flu vaccine deliveries
to our
um primary care networks and to the
community pharmacies as well so that is
starting from the 6th of september as i
say no current update in terms of the um
booster programme
and as ellen has mentioned um and you
know there are meetings happening as we
speak at a national level there's quite
a lot in the press um about the waning
of the vaccine which is quite normal in
any vaccination program but the um
effectiveness and you know the the the
ability of the vaccine to prevent
serious um illnesses is the evidence is
absolutely there so just to back up
really what eleanor and other colleagues
have said and just to continue to
encourage um that uptake
so i think that's all i had on my list
but
always happy to take questions
thank you rebecca any questions at all
not a question but just on the flu
program
although we had hoped and we were still
waiting to hear about the national
booster program if you're invited for a
flu vaccine please do go to get your flu
vaccination as soon as you're invited we
really don't want anyone getting flu so
don't wait
um get your flu vaccine as soon as
you're invited and then
some there may or may not be a national
cove booster program and it's not clear
yet even if there is which which cohorts
of people will be invited it may just be
the very oldest people um so don't delay
having flu because you think you might
be able to combine it with covid go and
get the flu vaccine
and make sure that you're you're
protected against flu we really don't
want anyone getting flu
so get that even if it means you might
have to have two trips do don't wait
thank you elena indeed
thank you rebecca i don't see any
questions thank you very much indeed um
so the next title on the agenda is
community engagement and i've seen quite
a lot on social media about this nigel
so over to you and good morning
good morning yes so uh the main thing
that i wanted to give an update today on
is our summer program
so um as i think we've mentioned before
the summer program is running for the
four weeks of august so we've been
spending a week in each of the four
neighborhoods uh we're now into our
final week so the programme
was called shape up for summer and is
focused on promoting general messaging
which eleanor and the public health team
um
gave to us and it's about leading a
healthy lifestyle this summer in order
to help reduce the risks of covid as
well as other diseases so uh we've been
promoting the program
by the council on social media our
networks and also for the community hubs
and the gps
so we started first of all in the
central area then we moved on to west
area last week we were in the north and
in our final week this week we are in
the south of the borough
so each week we've been a different
venue on the monday wednesday friday um
so for example on monday this week we
were in john lee park and today we are
at the brewwood community center in
timperley
so the conversations activities have
been really really well received by the
community we've had lots of interactions
with families um the emphasis has been
on making it fun and interactive
and we've been putting on physical
activities which children in particular
have really been getting involved in uh
we found that the events in parks have
probably uh been worked best you know in
terms of busier better for having sort
of getting people involved and has led
to more engagement
we wanted to say a big thank you to the
volunteers who've supported us as well
as the officers from the council's
testing team who have also been
brilliant in helping us
um so in terms of numbers today we've
engaged with around 350 people in the
first three weeks in the community and
uh around 450 adults children have also
taken part in all the different
activities
and some of the initial findings that
we've found is that the vast majority of
people um well over 80 percent of people
that we spoke to kind of feel
safe
and they're glad to be out and about
doing more so that's that's a real
positive
and although some people are still
experiencing some anxieties and worries
around covid which is to be expected as
well as other uh concerns they may have
around things such as redundancy or
other health worries
um and also we're finding that some
people are still experiencing social
isolation particularly those working
from home still
um the messaging that we've given out
around healthier lifestyle in the in
order to improve resilience and covert
and other diseases has been received
really positively
and people have also been sharing their
own stories around improving health
joined lockdown
and their team are you know where they
can they are signposting people to other
services local groups etc for
support where that's appropriate
uh just in terms of a little bit of
feedback from uh in terms of
vaccinations we found that
around three-quarters of people have had
both doses around 10
uh have had their first dose and around
another 10 approximately have not been
vaccinated with a smaller number
still waiting for their vaccination and
some of the reasons
like i say not many people that we've
spoken to have not had the vaccine but
the kind of reasons that they have cited
are
existing health conditions that they
have they're concerned around side
effects or they believe that not enough
research has been done
into the vaccines so
that's the findings that we found from
the summer program like i say which has
gone really really well and we're just
in that final week now um just a couple
of things i wanted to mention we did a
um
we piloted a
questionnaire
uh at the start of the month with in the
north of the borough which uh i did
mention at the engagement board uh
about a month ago that we were going to
be undertaking this survey
so this was an evidence-based
questionnaire which was developed by the
public health team to try and understand
better understand the reasons why some
people have not yet had the vaccine
the number that we've people that spoke
to uh was small because it was just a
pilot but it did give us some valuable
insight
um
and what we found was that uh of those
that were not yet vaccinated
that we spoke to people
knew where to receive a vaccine and
recognize it was an easy process if they
wanted to get a vaccine for themselves
um and of those who had not yet had the
vaccine roughly half of them had no
intention of getting the vaccine
and
some of the reasons cited were things
like uh health-related concerns or
distrust in the vaccine or that they'd
seen some negative news surrounding the
vaccine
so the findings of that survey will be
discussed further at the vaccine equity
group which we meet every week to
help improve vaccine access and
confidence and this will help
direct the team in terms of further
engagement activity going forwards
so those are the two things i wanted to
focus on from the engagement team i've
also got a short comms update from um
ellie caddick who is on league today but
she just wanted me to mention a few
points
so firstly um page is now live on the
ccg website to promote the walk-in
vaccination clinics
so and that is just being optimized at
the moment to make it uh make sure that
people find it very quickly when they
google
um but this page will be updated weekly
so that people get uh up-to-date
information on where the walk-in clinics
are in trafford the comps team are
looking to do some further outdoor
advertising in the north and central
areas to promote uptake to the under 30s
and also they'll be doing some
continuing with a digital advertising
campaign for the under 30s
which is directing people to the nhs
booking system and the final thing ellie
wanted me to mention was for 16 and 17
year olds the call to action is for
people to visit the national nhs
walk-in clinic page which has a search
engine uh to find clinics
for uh 16 or 17 year olds
although this information will also be
on the ccg
web page which i mentioned earlier
that's the update for me thank you uh
thank you nigel and and thank you for
covering um ellie's uh comms update
because i did actually how did he send
it to him and i was going to include it
at the end but you've stolen my thunder
on that one so thank you very much any
questions at all for uh nigel
yeah tell us accordingly um yeah i think
we're doing really well um
there's obviously a uh a section of the
community that are harder to get the
harder to lead to the vaccination center
i'm wondering um
i know it's
it sounds almost opportunistic
but we aren't expecting um
rates to go up when schools go back um
and in a sense are we able to ride that
wave are we in a position to sort of
really make one last push to try and get
some of those difficult um
people to get to the vaccination center
so it's really um
when rates go up are we able to sort of
say yeah rates are really
difficult now get that it's absolutely
definitely
necessary for you to get vaccinated at
this moment that's really all but i
think you're doing an excellent job
thanks
thank you council accordingly for that
um
i can echo exactly i do think an
excellent job has been done and uh and i
do know that we continue to strive
to get as many people vaccinated as
possible and that that work will
continue
i don't either oh yes counselor
blackburn thank you
thank you could i ask is there
any evidence as to which gender are not
wanting to be vaccinated either sort of
one or the other
and secondly it's probably for you know
for ellie maybe to take up um would
manu lancashire crickets or altering mfc
consider um doing something prior to
kickoff and encouraging people to get
vaccinated who haven't been thank you
eleanor is that something we can we can
look at
yes we certainly can and we we um i
think that's a really good idea asking
them to do that encouragement i think
with some of the people now who are
choosing not to be vaccinated it is a
very active choice
um we've made you know vaccination is
very available and we've really been
pushing it very very hard the ccg has
been working tremendously hard on this
um including you know direct contact
from gps and so on so for some people
there is just a huge suspicion of the
vaccination and and huge anxieties about
it and to be fair i think you know with
those people it's
really you're not we're not going to
change their mind at this point what we
need to do is just make sure everybody
knows that should their minds change
it's available to them but jill has been
working on this more specifically so i
think she'll be able to answer more of
um those points so jilla
thanks yeah so just to respond to the
first part of your question counselor
blackburn um it was just a pilot and so
the numbers were quite small
uh i think too small for us to really be
able to say if there was a real gender
difference but now that we've completed
the pilot and taken some learning from
that we do
intend to
roll that out more widely and survey
other areas
so that will increase our sample size
and
therefore you know the robustness of the
data and we might then be able to drill
down to subgroups and
and have that level of understanding but
there wasn't anything jumping out from
the pilot that indicated there was an
imbalance between uh men and women on
vaccine hesitancy and as i say we will
be rolling it out further
thank you chiller um
just coming back to council blackmon's
point about manchester united and and
the cricket i can tell you that i have i
do know two people who both double
vaccinated they went to the first game
at manchester united and they have both
come down with kobe 19 and one of them
has been very poorly
um so it is you know in the i would
argue in the club's interest perhaps
help us along those lines if we can
possibly get them to do some
announcements that'll be really useful
any further questions at all
well that brings us to the the end of
the agenda the next meeting is on the
8th of september and i'm going to offer
my apologies now because i will be on
annual leave and i've arranged for alex
to contact george devlin so i think
we'll be back to chair the next meeting
for us so i'll i'm off for a fortnight
from friday
and
just continue to enjoy this the summer
and i i i'm rather reliably informed the
sun is definitely coming out this week
elena
thank you very much for your attendance
thank you i'll hold you to that
okay
bye